if there's one universal belief that
unites people everywhere it's that
everyone else is an idiot now I met a
lot of geeks in the same sense that a
honey bee is met a lot of honey bees and
I used to think that this was an
attitude peculiar to the gig mindset
this belief that your personal worth
could be measured by your grasp of
regular expressions and whether you
realize that the doctor in Doctor Who is
not actually named doctor who as it
turns out though everybody thinks this
like if you get on the bus you'll end up
sitting in front of some guy who lost
three fingers in a panini accident and
he's got a garage full of ketchup
packets because you never know and he's
talking to a lady who doesn't buy lunch
meat and sealed packages because it
gives off rays and who is somehow
managed to put her high-heeled shoes on
backwards and they'll be talking to each
other what will they be saying oh man
you know everyone's an idiot but us oh
yeah I completely agreed they're all
just completely stupid yep are you gonna
use that ketchup packet so if everyone
thinks is the most sensible person on
the planet then how do you know who
really is I mean there has to be some
objective way to measure intelligence IQ
tests you know one of the first things I
learned on the web back in the day is it
if someone boasts about their IQ on
their webpage there's no reason to read
any further because what follows is
going to be a steady stream of highly
refined nonsense I have an IQ of 176 so
you can believe me when I tell you that
the true reason for declining SATs
course it's the advent of laser printing
you see kids used to have to read these
faded purple mimeograph handed out in
class they actually had to work to read
and that made them smarter money I mean
people who are rich must know something
they're rich problem with that is that
when your neighbor wins the lottery and
in celebration sets his lawn on fire
you're going to have to accept his
mental superiority that seems like a
problem how about happiness that guy
front of you in the line at subway who
keeps singing the five-dollar footlong
song over and over seems pretty happy
maybe it's his little stuffed Ocelot
that he keeps fondling or maybe he just
really likes the little hat he made out
of drinking straws in twine either way
you know I'm really not in a hurry to
take a community college course from him
so obviously the only quality that
really separates the bright from the
dull is the ability to recognize
intelligence when you see it for
instance you and I are clearly smart
because we know how dumb everyone else
is however everyone else seems to think
that they're smart when they're not
which just proves what idiots they are
now you may not agree that this is the
only objective way to measure
intelligence and if you don't that kind
of shows which group you're in
you